[Music]
my name is Paul Gil I'm a tech lead for
Arista networks I I have an accident but
I'm actually based here in New York City
and I build or designed or help build
and design uh Enterprise networks uh but
what we do is a plumbing uh so I'm not
going to talk about agents but more kind
of how you train uh models what the
infrastructure looks like and how you do
inferencing on on the infrastructure uh
I I I normally teach people uh the very
basic stuff so I I you guys probably
know this already but these are new
terms for us when when we built computer
networks people will come to us and say
job completion time uh barrier I'm I'm
pretty sure you guys know that the the
INF
and the question I get all the time is
you know we we can build a network to
train a model there's a an algorithm
maybe you can use to to look at what you
what you need uh but then you know
what's inference and you know it's
changed a lot now because of chain of fa
and reasoning models the inference is a
lot different it used to be X but now
it's
y uh I'm pretty sure you guys have seen
this slide but I use these just to talk
to Enterprises around kind of what they
might be thinking in GPU size uh this uh
wed Sosa came up Dr wed Sosa came up
with this on the left there is the
training and on the right there is the
inference and it's kind of you know on
one you have times 18 times the other
times two again I think that changes now
with Chain of Thought and reasoning not
too sure kind of which way it's going to
go and at the bottom there was a really
interesting one again which I show
customers cuz I most of the Enterprises
I talk to kind of don't understand
models and how they work can train in I
know a little but not a lot but you know
the the the the the model they trained
down here was 248 gpus for one to two
months and then when you go to inference
after fine June in alignment it's four
h100s for inference so we talk to people
about building different types of
networks which I'll speak about but uh
you know kind of I always start at the
beginning and you know this is I got
this slide and I think it's really
interesting you know llms were kind of
just tiny little bit of inference but
now with the the Next Generation models
it's a lot so this is what we build or I
I build uh and these are new
terminologist for us from the networking
world uh backend Network so this is
where you connect gpus to when we build
these networks uh they're completely
isolated cuz gpus are really really
expensive they take a lot of power uh
and they're really hard to get old of so
when people build AI networks in the
Enterprise uh we don't connect nothing
else to the these networks the the
bottom part of that the back end Network
there's eight gpus per pool on those
servers and they can be Nvidia they can
be super micro they can be be whatever
they will go into a high-speed switch at
the bottom there uh you have a leaf
switch and a spine switch and nothing
else attaches to that Network and then
on the front end network is where you
get sto storage from the Train the model
obviously you know it the gpus
synchronize they do something they
calculate they produce an algorithm and
they call for more data and that's kind
of the cycle the front end network is
not as intense as the back end the
backend Network depending on the model
that you train uh they the gpus will
actually work at 400 GB and for for us
in the Enterprise you know and I've
built some big big data centers but I've
never seen anything like that so this is
in the networking world this is a
completely new world to us and we we
make the networks as simple as possible
because again these are really expensive
and people want to get their money's
worth they want these running
24x7 uh so we you do IB ibgp or ebgp
just a really simple
protocols uh I'm sure most you have seen
this but again I I kind of teach this I
uh the the this was an infrastructure
presentation but you know that's kind of
the back of a h100 probably the most
popular it is actually the most popular
uh uh AI server out there right now you
can see in the middle there there's four
ports but those four ports are broken
out into two so there's eight ports
those are the GPU ports there and then
kind of over to the left there there's
the ethernet ports so that's what we
connect to we've never seen anything
like this before you know when you first
speak to people about this you know I've
seen servers with 400 gig you know and I
do a lot of the big Financial networks
but never before have we seen servers
that can put this type of traffic onto a
network
uh yeah we always they always ask me
about this and you know I got this from
an Nvidia slide it's stand there but you
know there's this thing called scale up
and scale out I'm not really sure scale
up you know when when you buy when my
customers buy these servers that always
have eight gpus in it you can't add
anything to an Nvidia server you get the
djx the if you go with the Outsource
model it's a hgx or it's a third party
you don't really add things to it but so
I don't see scale up but scale you know
obviously you can build a we we build a
network so that you can add more gpus we
can start very small and we can go up to
you know hundreds of thousands of gpus
not in the Enterprise but the cloud
scale guys
do so so what's different uh you know
for us again it's there's it's hardware
and software the hardware are those gpus
we're not used to them uh the first time
I tried to configure one it took me
hours and hours but I'd never seen them
before whereas other stuff I've seen
pretty quickly you know you have
software so Cuda and nickel are probably
you know two of the biggest protocols
and you you guys know more about that
than me but we had to kind of understand
not Cuda but nickel because it has a
collective so we had to understand kind
of how a collective works because that
will put uh traffic onto the network in
a certain way uh the hardware was
completely different again you know we
had the eight uh 400 gig PS and the four
400 gig PS facing the the the front end
netor work totally new to
us the other thing was Data Center
applications kind of web app database
they're really easy uh they go from one
to the other and in different parts of
the network and if one fails you you
have some kind of low balance in or fa
and it fails over uh this is AI networks
not like that the gpus all speak they'll
talk to each other they'll get stuff
they'll send stuff and if one fails the
the job might fail it might recover but
it's a different concept cept to us so
it's it's it's hard to imagine uh and
traffic is bursty because all of these
gpus if you have th000 gpus of 400 gig
they will all burst at the same time and
if you if they can they will burst at
400 gig so there's a lot of traffic on
the network and I've never seen anything
like that so when we build these
networks we don't build them over
subscribe we build them one to one uh
might in the data center world we used
to do 1 to 10 it went down to probably 1
to 3 three but never one to one because
it's just really expensive to to to
build that kind of bandwidth but with AI
networks we need to so we have no over
subscription in the network and from
from our point of view if you look at
what one of these servers can put on the
network you know just a h100 is 8 400
gig gpus and 4 400 gig is 4.8 terabytes
which is and that's just one server the
storage size the the the front end
probably nowhere near that but the back
end is always wire rate and then 800 gig
is probably you know the bees are just
around the corner I think in March
there'll be releas I think there's some
people that have them and those are 800
gig we support 800 gig today on the
network but each one of those servers in
there a possible 9.6 terabytes per
server and you most people in my world
in the in the Enterprise world come from
servers at maybe 1 2 3 or four 100 Gig
ethernet but nothing like uh 9.6
terabytes per
server so the other problem we have is
the traffic patterns when we load
balance from kind of leaf to spine we
use a thing called entropy which is the
five tle IP address port a MAC address
and we do pretty good low balancing but
with gpus it's just one IP address and
it can sometimes match to a single
Uplink and oversubscribe it which would
be really bad because your start
dropping an awful lot of packets so we
have to take a lot of Care on how we low
balance within the AI Network or how we
build the back end and the front end so
we have some pretty cool tools where we
don't now look at the five topples we
actually low balance on the percent of
bandwidth that's being used on the
Uplink and we can get up to about 93%
utilization on all the uplinks to the
down links which is pretty
good uh you know and again one thing
that's really new to us is a single GPU
can you or a set of gpus if they fail uh
sometimes the model will stop I know
checkpoints but uh a single fit GPU fail
is a problem for us and if one of the
big problems that's we've always add is
Optics and transceivers and Doms which
is the rates and the the loss between
them and the cables Etc and when you
start building these networks with
thousands of gpus you will have a lot of
cable problems and you will have a lot
of GPU problems so it's it's really hard
for us because we again this world is is
new to us the last year or
so uh Power I you know power is you
could you know you've read the
newspapers you know everyone's trying to
buy buy nuclear power stations to power
these
things the the average rack in the data
center today is about 7kw to 15 KW and
you can put like you know 10 one one IU
Rex into those and you'll be fine
and when customers come to me say yeah
we finally got gpus whatever and I say
to them you know what kind of RS have
you got and they said well we're going
to put them in and then you could only
put one of these servers in one of those
RS because they they actually draw with
8 gpus 10.2 KW so you need new racks uh
most Enterprises now waking up to this
and they're building racks between 100
200 KW and they're water called there's
no way you could air call them in a data
center so that's a whole new concept to
people as well is water called
rxs uh traffic is is both ways which
again is new to us so north south you
know in a regular data center you have
users coming in database app web
whatever and it comes in it goes out but
in the AI world when the gpus speak that
traffic is east west because it's
speaking amongst each other uh and then
when they ask for more data from the
storage Network it's north south so you
have both traffic patterns the east west
is really bad that's kind of where they
run wire rate the front end to the
storage is much more more calmer because
most storage vendors can't put that kind
of traffic on on the on the network
right now I'm pretty sure they will one
day but they're more around 100 200
gig uh and you know in a network there's
a certain amount of buffering on these
switches and buffering is bad because it
means it can't send traffic somewhere
because something else is is not
receiving the traffic so you need a
congestion control and feedback uh and
right now we use something called Rocky
V2 which is two parts of Rocky V2
there's a PFC and an ecn uh if you were
building an AI Network your engineers
your network Engineers will definitely
know about this ecn is an endtoend flow
control where if traffic if if traffic
is if there's congestion somewhere in
network packets are marked they go to
the receiver the receiver sends back to
the sender you need to slow down because
there's congestion and it goes for an
algorithm it pauses for a while it slows
down and if it doesn't get any more ECM
packets it speeds up again uh and PFC is
basically stop uh my buffers are full I
can't take anym so it kind of is a dead
stop so you have kind of a a slow uh
feedback mechanism with vcn and the kind
of an emergency stop with
PFC the networks we build are really
simple we don't uh have things like in
regular data centers we have DMZ with
firewalls low balances Etc we have
connections to the internet we have L4
through 7 service a whole bunch of stuff
when we build these networks they're
totally isolated uh the GPU the the back
end is completely isolated the front end
possibly could have connections to
something but even then it's so
expensive to build you you don't want to
take the
chance uh on demand the applications
that we're used to you know if it fouls
or something fouls something will
recover and you know you you may get a a
little skip or a jump but if you've done
the right thing it's not going to be
that bad in this world if something
fouls the model May foul and you the
call that you get into the Operation
Center is different call than you get
that if you're you're at kind of
restarted and everything's good
again uh the other thing is collectives
you know obviously nickel will go out
and work out kind of where the GPU gpus
are and what to do with it but there's
kind of different design so I tell my
customers that speak to your data
scientist and your your uh your
programmers developers and find out kind
of what they're doing and what kind of
models they're building because it can
can affect the network on kind of how
you build it and how you design
it so Network's totally isolated things
are moving fast we're at 800 gig right
now uh uh which is you know we have been
for probably a year we will see 1.6
terabytes on the network probably end of
this year uh early
2027 and it will just keep grind and
grind and grind and these models will
get bigger and bigger and consume more
and more more I'm pretty
sure uh visibility in Telemetry I you
know all my customers the call that they
get when a model fails because the
network is a problem is a different core
than they used to so we put different
uh Telemetry and visibility in there to
make sure that if things are going wrong
on the network that you know they know
about it hopefully before they get that
call so yeah I work for Arista our
operating system is called EOS and we
have a whole bunch of features there so
if you were building an AI Network I'm
not sure that you guys speak to the
engineers but this is the type of things
we talk about uh lossless ethernet
everyone's thinks that you you know when
you train a model you can't drop packets
I I've seen it and you can I think drop
packets are okay consistent latency is
okay but if you drop so many packets
obviously it's a problem so flow control
loss of EET is really key ecn and PFC
are part of that as I said before
they're flow control mechanisms one is a
slow down please and the other one is a
stop and as you know because gep gpus
are synchronized if something slows down
you slow down one pull one GPU
everything slows down so you really got
to be on top of kind of the over
subscription and if you are getting Qin
where is
it uh we we have really good buffer uh
we can adjust buffers we have different
kinds of switches for different places
in the network but we found that models
send and receive a particular size
packet and what we do is we adjust those
buffers to accept those types of packets
buffering is a really expensive
commodity in switches in networking and
if you can find a way to allocate the
buffer because exactly tuned to the
packet sizes it's a win-win uh and we
we've worked out how to do that which is
good uh yeah monitoring is really key
for us uh I tell my customers there's
probably five things you want to do one
of them is RDMA you know uh these
networks train using RDMA you know uh
which is memory to memory rights rather
than going CPU to memory and RDMA is a a
complex protocol and it has 10 or 12
maybe more kind of error codes so if the
network starts seeing problems uh and
starts dropping packets rather than just
drop the packet on the floor we can
actually copy that packet to a buffer or
send it somewhere or just just the
headers and and why we dropped that
packet and if you think about it's
really cool like most networks will in
congestion your buffer fills up is
you're going to drop the packets we'll
drop the packet but we'll actually take
a snapshot of the packet and the headers
any rme information in it and we'll tell
you why we dropped
it uh another thing we have which is
really we have an AI agent uh you know
from the networking point of view we can
look at what's going on but we don't
really have any visibility into the GPU
so now we have an agent which is an API
uh and some code that we load on the the
gpus in Nvidia and they will speak to
the switch so that agent will say to the
switch how are you configured so PFC and
e those flow control mechanisms have to
be configured correctly cuz if they're
not it will be a disaster so the the GPU
will speak to the switch and say this is
how I'm configured the switch will say
yeah you're good we understand each
other and the second thing it does it
gives you a whole bunch of statistics
about packets received packets sent RDMA
errors RDMA issues in there so you can
can correlate now if the problem is a
GPU or if it's a network which is a huge
step forward for for us
uh another really cool feature we have
is uh smart system upgrade you know if
you used the routers and switches you
know you have to upgrade the software
sometimes uh sometimes to get new
features sometimes to fix pts which are
security vulnerabilities on that switch
uh we've worked out a way now that we
can do that you can upgrade code without
actually taking the switch offline so
you know if you have 1,24 gpus with 64
switches in your network you actually
can upgrade those and the gpus can keep
working so it's a real big step forward
for
us so you for us again I I don't know if
but no over subscription on the back end
you can't because the gpus use
everything you give them address- wise
is really important for us it's a it's a
Point to-point connection so it's sl30
31s you could use IPv6 if you have ipv4
problems address space problems all my
customers I tell bgp because it's the
best protocol out there it's really
simple and it's really quick uh evpm VXL
if you have multi tency if you have a
lot of different business units lines of
business uh using the network you need
things like advaned low balancing we
have a couple of different we we
actually look at the collective that
you're running low balance on that
Collective Now which we call cluster low
balancing you could deploy It Rocky I
tell all my customers do it because if
you don't your Network's going to melt
down you're not going to know why these
things will give you an early warning
system that you need to do something
with your network so that they're really
key to have and visibility in Telemetry
is is really good at all times because
in the network knock or the Operation
Center you always want to be aware of
the problem before you get the call from
the developers and the people that have
paid a lot of money for that
Network I'm running out of time here but
this is kind of 1,400 gig cluster what
it would look like spine and leaf uh
again no over subscription 800 gig links
between the leaf and spine 400 gig down
to the
gpus this is a 4,000
cluster these ones these are the bigger
boxes these are 16 slot one of these
boxes can take 576 800 gig gpus so 1150
to 400 gig gpus so if you're building
clusters with thousands of gpus then
this would be the box for you the 7800
series and and putting it together this
is kind of what we would build there's
three networks here there's a backend
Network where your gpus live there's a
front end Network where the storage live
and then there's the the the inference
that you take the model you put it
somewhere
else I'm out of time I do not come in so
I'm guess I'm not so so so the other
thing is you know there's Ultra ethernet
Consortium you I don't know if it's
interest you ethernet hasn't changed
it's built probably 30 years uh there's
some things it could do better around
congestion control around packet
spraying around the Nicks talking to
each other so there's this thing called
Ultra EET Consortium version 10 will be
ratified probably q1
2025 and it's a kind of different way of
building networks and you probably won't
see them until Q3 Q4 but most of the
clad scale guys were kind of really keen
on this because it it puts a lot more
into the ncks and takes a lot more out
out of the Network so we just get we can
do what we're good at which is forward
in
packets so summary you know for us we
have the front end which is storage the
back end which is the really important
part for us uh that part is really
bursty uh the gpus are all synced so
they send and receive at the same time
and if you have a slow GPU that's a
barrier because it stops everyone else
job completion time is what matters to
us if you know we get the call that you
know my job completion time was 1 hour
yesterday it's 4 days today you know
it's probably our problem uh you know
models can checkpoint but they're really
expensive you guys know
that and I'm done
[Music]